primarily with the tempemptations.
My heartfelt condolences go out
to his family and friends.
>> Absolutely.
>>> Also this morning, the
company that owns Madison square
garden, radio city music hall
and other famous New York venues
says that all lawyers who work
at firms representing a client
suing them are banned.
Msg entertainment is denying
entry to anyone on its exclusion
list, from attending concerts or
sporting events.
Here's what's a key part of
this.
They are using facial
recognition technology to do it.
CNN's Omar Jiminez is covering
this story.
This is remarkable.
"A," because of the facial
recognition aspect, but "B,"
it's not just the attorneys who
are involved in the suing.
It's any attorneys that work at
firms that are representing
those who are suing these
venues.
>> And I think that was the
surprise for a lot of people.
It's like, I'm not even involved
in the litigation of this, and
all of a sudden, I am banned, at
least temporarily as well.
And it's part of what New York
attorney general Letitia James
is concerned about here.
Not just potentially dissuading
those from holding Madison
square garden entertainment
potentially accountable, but
also the technology involved
with it.
Msg maintains that they are
fully within their rights.
>> Come up on matching somebody
on a facial recognition list.
>> He was recognized on facial
recognition cameras, then
confronted.
>> Are you Benjamin norry?
>> Yes.
>> This is how lawyer Benjamin
Norman was greeted.
>> The ticket has been revoked
and you are not permitted in the
building.
>> It's because norren works for
a law firm representing ticket
brokers in a lawsuit against
Madison square garden
entertainment.
All of the roughly 60 lawyers at
his firm are also banned until
the litigation is resolved.
>> We received a letter from msg
stating that because of this
litigation, all attorneys in our
firm, even those attorneys who
have nothing to do whatsoever
with the litigation, will be
barred for the duration of the
litigation.
>> Reporter: The firm's
co-founding partner has been a
season ticket holder for 47
years.
He believes here, he's being
retaliated against.
>> The focus of their ban is to
dissuade people from suing
Madison square garden.
If you have to think about, do I
have a choice of being banned
and representing somebody,
somebody is going to say, I
don't need that aggravation.
I'm not going to take that.
>> Reporter: Their firm is among
dozens temporarily banned from
msg properties, including radio
city music hall, while they
represent clients suing the
garden.
New York attorney general
Letitia James believes they may
be violating state and city
laws, writing to them in part,
forbidding entry to lawyers
representing clients who have
engaged in litigation against a
company may dissuade such
lawyers from taking on
legitimate cases.
Days later, Madison square
garden emphasized it's a private
business and in compliance with
all laws, writing in part, the
attorneys prohibited from
attending includes money
grabbers who capitalize on the
misfortune of others.
This includes attorneys
representing ticket scalpers,
personal injury claims, and
class action litigations, but
does not include claims related
to sexual harassment or
employment discrimination.
>> You get to say who you serve.
And if it's somebody who is
suing you and trying to put you
out of business or take your
money from you, right, et
cetera, you have a right to be,
yes, a little unhappy about it.
>> You know, it doesn't seem
like they're letting up.
If anything, they've been
doubling down.
>> No, no, tripling down, even.
>> Some experts believe it's a
slippery slope and not just the
discretionary power of who else
could be flagged in the future,
but one method being used to
enforce it.
Even if it is legal.
>> I have read their privacy
policy.
They explicitly say that the
biometrics that they capture
from you can be used for any
purpose that would benefit their
economic interest.
There's all sorts of things they
could be doing with face
recognition, and there's so much
minimal transparency around it,
because they're a private
company.
>> Some don't believe it should
be used at all.
>> It's so primed to be misused.
It's so prone to discrimination.
And I am terrified of the day
where we allow companies to use
so many forms of tracking and
surveillance that, you know, we
end up in the middle of one of
the largest cities on the planet
without any place we can
actually go, while keeping our
privacy.
>> Now, Madison square garden
says they've been using facial
recognition to help create a
safe environment since 2018.
But there are a lot of factors
here that people are concerned
about.
They've gone until February 13th
to respond to attorney general
James' inquiries.
Obviously, though, still an
ongoing battle here.